así
en la última elección exploramos el
comportamiento geométrico de las cámaras
y vimos cómo la luz rebotaba en los
objetos pasaba a través de un pequeño
agujero o apertura y golpeaba el plano
de la imagen uno de los conceptos
importantes que abordamos fue la
profundidad de campo que es la región en
donde los objetos aparecen enfocados
fuera de esta los objetos se ven
borrosos cuando un punto en una imagen
está desenfocado se convierte en un
círculo borroso conocido como círculo de
confusión en esta lección
desarrollaremos las ecuaciones
algebraicas que nos indican exactamente
en donde entran en foco los objetos y
qué tan grande será el círculo de
confusión si algo está desenfocado estas
ecuaciones nos permitirán crear cámaras
virtuales para generar imágenes
espectaculares como esta toma
para empezar volvamos a nuestra cámara
estenopeica como siempre cuando
reducimos la distancia entre la
geometría y el álgebra necesitamos
introducir un sistema de coordenadas es
conveniente elegir nuestro sistema de
coordenadas de manera que el agujero
esté en el punto del origen justo aquí
ahora imaginemos que nuestra escena está
a la derecha y supongamos que el plano
de la imagen dentro de nuestra cámara se
encuentra a cierta distancia a la
izquierda del agujero llamemos y a esta
distancia ahora tomemos en cuenta un
punto en algún objeto de nuestra escena
llamemos a este punto x 0,0 parte de la
luz del entorno que ilumine este punto
rebota hacia la cámara atraviese el
agujero e ilumina el plano de la imagen
llamemos x 1,1 al sitio del plano de la
imagen iluminado entonces nuestra
primera pregunta es cuál es x1
1 una manera de averiguarlo es
utilizando la forma pendiente
intersección de una recta la pendiente
del rayo de luz es de 0 sobre x0 y la
intersección de iu es cero porque
dijimos que este rayo pasa a través del
punto del origen esto es la ecuación del
rayo es exactamente igual a 10 0 sobre x
0 por x + 0 o simplemente igual a 10 0
sobre x 0 x
ahora bien x 1,1 el punto que estamos
buscando también está en este rayo por
lo que debemos cumplir con la ecuación
de esta recta
esto quiere decir que llegó uno es igual
a 0 sobre x 0 por x 1 observa que el
diagrama nos indica que x1 es negativo y
está a una distancia y del origen es
decir sabemos que x1 es igual a menos y
por último para obtener de uno solo
hacemos la sustitución que nos da de uno
igual a menos de cero sobre x0 por y
observa que el punto es cero es positivo
pero el punto equivalente en el plano es
negativo por eso tenemos una imagen
invertida bien hagamos una pausa aquí
para que te familiarices con esto antes
de que añadamos una lente a nuestra
cámara